so the New York Times just published an
extremely racist screed and they it
starts with the tweet they they publish
this article they tweeted it out the
tweet that accompanied the article said
New Hampshire is 94% white it is now
trying to figure out how to change that
and the article itself is is
fantastically bigoted so I want to just
read you the first few paragraphs of
this article just so you can fully
comprehend the racism that we're dealing
with here so this is what it says
Catalina celentano used to hold training
sessions for hospital workers in Lynn
Massachusetts to familiarize them with
the cultures of patients from Cambodia
Russia and the Dominican Republic when
she moved to New Hampshire she suddenly
found herself in an ethnic vacuum now
maybe we should pause there for just a
moment in ethnic vacuum
so what she she went to New Hampshire
she discovered that the people in New
Hampshire have no ethnicities but there
are there are no ethnicities it's a
vacuum of ethnicity so these are these
are human beings who are walking around
and living and they have zero at what so
where did they come from do they sprout
out of the ground did they fall from the
sky like like dewdrops what happened
no no even white people have ethnicities
to insinuate that white people have no
ethnicity is jet it's it's not only
insulting but it's crazy it's like when
you hear it's like when we hear well
there are people of color and white
people it's no I I have a color also I
mean it might be a lighter color but I
definitely have a color I don't not I'm
not colourless for goodness sake I mean
if if I landed if you came to the earth
from like an alien planet and you didn't
know anything about the human species
and then you started hearing well there
are people of color and then white
people I would imagine so what I would
imagine are like normal creatures who
have color and then I would imagine
white people as being these translucent
colorless monstrous cities walking
around where you could see their bones
through their skin because they have no
color it just it doesn't make any sense
but
that's one thing at least that's kind of
a figure of speech I understand but to
say it's an ethnic vacuum because it's
all it's it's a bunch of Caucasians
living there it's just it would be like
if I move too if I move to Mongolia and
discovered to my horror that it's only a
bunch of Mongolians living there and I
said this is an ethnic vacuum there's no
there's there are no ethnicities here
and someone said well they're Mongolians
here what yeah but except for them
except for them in Mongolia there's
nobody else what's going on
celentano mrs. Halliburton Oh said I
went from being able to speak Spanish
every day to not speaking Spanish at all
because there wasn't anyone to speak
Spanish to the only person I spoke
Spanish with was a cleaning lady and she
moved back to Colombia
okay I don't really think you have a
right to complain
that people in an in a state in the
United States of America only speak
English that is after all traditionally
in the language that we speak here so
once again it would be like if I went to
South Korea and then complaining that
everyone's speaking Korean here what's
going on I mean back home back back home
I I spoke English every day then I moved
to I moved to South Korea but I haven't
spoken English in days what's happening
I don't understand what could have
possibly happened what what change
occurred I'm so confused
whatever whatever happened to the whole
I I guess we've completely done away
with the idea of assimilation at this
point haven't we of course we did away
with that a long time ago now we don't
even pretend we don't even pretend that
assimilation is the goal
so that we're actually now writing
articles lamenting the fact that a
native Spanish speaker moved to New
Hampshire and has to speak English god
forbid she had to assimilate in one in
in the most basic way of speaking the
language that people speak there now the
article now let's get to the really
racist part here it says New Hampshire
like its neighbor Vermont and Maine is
nearly all white shame on them shame on
them for being all white how dare you
this has posed an array of problems for
new arrivals who often find themselves
isolated and alone without the comfort
and support of the built in community it
also posed problems for employers in
these states where it could be a barrier
to recruiting and retaining workers of
different ethnicities and cultural
backgrounds the issue prompted about 100
business leaders government officials
and members of nonprofit organizations
to meet Thursday to search for ways that
New Hampshire which is 94 percent white
might lure other racial and ethnic
groups
which by the way is kind of just creepy
to speak of luring racial groups we've
got a we've got to lure some racial
groups in here you know cast out the
lure and reel em in
now so that we can really conceptualize
how racist this is let's just imagine
for a moment that we made it we changed
a couple of words in those last three
paragraphs just change a couple of words
around and let's go back and read it
again and let's see if we can really see
the racism this time all right
so imagine if the article said this
instead
Detroit like Atlanta and Birmingham is
nearly all black this has posed an array
of problems for new arrivals who often
find themselves isolated and alone
without the comfort and support of a
built in community it also posed
problems for employers in these states
where it could be a barrier to
recruiting and retaining workers of
different ethnicities the issue prompted
about 100 business leaders government
officials and members of nonprofit
organizations to meet Thursday to search
for ways that Detroit which is 83
percent black might lure other racial
and ethnic groups
so change just a few words and suddenly
it becomes extremely extremely racist
all you have to do is just swap out the
race that's being discussed for a
different race and all of a sudden the
the racism just jumps out at you
and it's actually I should amend that
it's not that it becomes racist all of a
sudden when you change out white for
black it's that now
the racism is apparent to even the most
obtuse observer it is obviously racist
to treat the preponderance of a certain
race in a certain area as an objective
problem it is racist to look at the
percentages of of different of you know
to look at a certain race and say oh
they have a majority percentage let's
try to lower their percentage just for
the sake of it just because we want
fewer of those types around here that is
the definition of racism it is racist to
treat a certain race as if its existence
in an area is a problem
now the only way to alleviate the racism
in this case and this is this is what
leftist will do especially leftist who
have been been recently Mis educated in
a in a you know
academic institution especially in
college because this is what they teach
you in college
what they teach in college now is that
racism by definition applies only to the
racism of white people but never to the
racism against white people now that is
not the definition that you're gonna
find in the dictionary if you look up
racism in the dictionary you won't find
that but this is the the definition of
racism that was invented by leftist in
the last you know a couple of decades
and now taught as fact it is a totally
arbitrary random made-up definition for
they took a word that had a real meaning
and then they just made up a new
definition and started teaching it at
school and said no race this is what
racism means now and now you'll have
left us anytime you talk about racism
they'll come in and they'll correct you
and they'll say well no actually racism
is all about power dynamics and whatever
group is in power can't be victims of
racism yeah who told you that where are
you getting that from no that's not what
it means
that maybe is what your college
professor told you but he made that up
that is not what the word means at all
if you hate a certain race or if you if
you're prejudiced against them you're
racist it doesn't matter nothing else
matters that's racism right there
and and and and also just by the way if
if racism if it's
if a non-white person can never be
guilty of racism on the basis that well
they don't have power and you know in
any way their hatred of white people is
justified so it's not right
well before we talk about the Fela we
won't even get to get into the fact that
if it's all about power dynamics then
how did this definition still hold even
when we had a black president but we
won't even get into that what about the
racism of non-white of a non-white
person towards other non-white groups so
what if a black person hates for
instance Asian people is that also not
racist
well I guess our nation's university
professors will tell us that that
doesn't exist there's no racism there
racism was is an invention of white
people and it doesn't exist anywhere
else in the world apparently now a
couple other points I want to make
first of all
let's talk about diversity
organic diversity that is diversity that
happens naturally over time is fine it's
a fine thing I wouldn't even call it
good I'd say it's it's fine it's like
just sort of neutral there's nothing
inherently problematic with a certain
race being the majority in a certain
area so there's nothing wrong with that
if you go to a town and it's just a
bunch of white people that's fine it
doesn't matter they're just people
living their lives in a place where they
want to live now if they if they had a
rule that excluded other races or they
other people of other races and
ethnicities tried to move in and they
were chased out of town well that's a
problem but that's not the case in like
New Hampshire if you go to New Hampshire
and you go to a small town in New
Hampshire you find a bunch of white
people they're not chasing anybody away
it's just they're living up in the
mountains in New Hampshire and that's
just nobody else has thought to move
there and live there so it's not a
problem so we can't say well you know
it's we could improve this area by
adding diversity you're not going to
improve it I'm not gonna say you're not
saying you make it worse either it's
just it does it's just a it's a lateral
move so you had a bunch of people with a
certain skin pigmentation and then you
brought in other people with with darker
pigmentation
okay great fine okay you didn't prove it
it's just they're still just people
living there that's all but again it's
fine
on the other hand engineered diversity
the diversity that happens when social
engineers look at a place and say there
are too many of this kind of race that
is bad okay that's a very bad form of
diversity it's very bad it's bad because
it's racist and racism in the name of
diversity is very self-defeating
and it's also bad because of the
arrogance involved I mean think of the
arrogance of the government officials
who sat down in New Hampshire and said
there are too many of this sort of
person we need to bring in a particular
percentage of these other kinds of
people that's what we need to do who are
you to determine that who puts you in
charge of that what do you mean there
are too many of that kind of person
what scale are you using who appointed
you arbiter of these things what do you
mean too many too few based on what
standard and how is that any of your
business or any of your concern it's not
it's not your job to organize the racial
makeup of society that's not what you're
supposed to be doing
you really don't need to have a very
in-depth knowledge of
history or world events to realize that
it is always bad news always bad news
when governments get into the business
of racial engineering that is never good
nothing good ever comes of that ever
second thing
this this stuff this this nonsense like
what we're talking about here with the
New York Times in New Hampshire
this is partly where white supremacism
comes from okay
now obviously white supremacism is a bad
thing just like racial supremacism in
any race is a bad thing
but so this is not obviously about
justifying white supremacism
it's about pointing out that white
supremacism and white racism which
certainly does exist is a social
phenomenon with various roots and this
is one of the roots
now the primary routes are bad home life
bad parenting lack of moral formation I
think any time you have racist people
that's gonna be a big part of it maybe
the primary part of it but when you've
got a white kid with that kind of
background and he emerges into a world
where his race is treated like it's
something he should apologize for where
his existence is seen as a problem as a
thing that has to be corrected and he's
told that like he doesn't even have an
ethnic identity whatsoever he is a
vacuum of ethnicity you're trying to
drain his identity from him
um then he's gonna understand like a
little bit ticked off about that and
maybe more ticked off than the average
person given the fact is that he has a
bad home life no moral formation so on
and so forth and then what happens there
is that the white supremacist can come
in and exploit his bad upbringing and
and his grievances about how his
identity is treated in society and they
can pretty easily recruit him based on
that this is how it works this is how
you make racists and bigots in any race
if you're interested in making more
racist this is the way to do it
great job New York Times I mean this is
exactly how you do it you make people
into racists by trying to make them feel
ashamed of their own race and their own
identity and their own history
if you go up to a crowd of people and
you whatever their race and you say to
them there are too many of you types and
by the way these are all the bad things
that you're guilty of apologize for
those things those things if you go up
to a group of people and you say that
you have just helped to push a certain
portion of those people into racism and
bigotry now it will be their fault
ultimately for succumbing to it but you
helped push them there so you also are
partly to blame
a lot of young white men who are already
lost and without identity are being
encouraged
you know into extremism because of how
their identity is treated by the media
academia and the government that's just
a fact of the matter
so what these institutions are doing
media academia and government they are
very deliberately sewing racial discord
they are not trying to to help with
assimilation and I try to help bring
people together they're not even trying
to help with diversity they are they are
trying to sow resentment and anarchy and
hatred between these different groups of
people
and when they succeed in doing what they
are clearly trying to do can we really
say that they bear none of the blame
whatsoever
this is just
I know we're told that like we're not
allowed to complain about because we're
white so you know if you're a white
person you can't complain about this
blatant bigoted nonsense
but no we can complain about it because
it is blatant bigoted nonsense
and it's harmful
now you and I as normal people we maybe
it'll read this kind of stuff and we can
laugh it off and say all these idiots
but
there are a lot of people who aren't as
normal and who are unstable
and they see this stuff and it's just
driving them whatever their race it's
just driving them in different
directions further away from each other
further into hatred and and resentment
so thanks a lot New York Times
mission accomplished great job all right
that's gonna do it for me guys thanks
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed